bonjour alors au risque d'en décevoir
certains et peut-être dans rassurer
d'autres je ne me mettrais pas tout nu
au contraire je vais plutôt essayer de
m'atteler à décortiquer à dépecer tous
ces comportements qui nous font nous
mettre une carapace sur le dos nous
habiller nous nous créer une vraie
mentaux qui nous empêchent d'être nous
mêmes au travail et au travers de mon
histoire je vais essayer de décrypter
ces comportements et de d'apporter plus
de naturalité à notre vie au travail de
tous les jours
alors je suis aujourd'hui le président
de bio groupe qui est une société qui
produit des boissons et des desserts
fermenté biologique et qui commercialise
ses produits dans toute l'europe et à
une petite échelle malgré tout et les
débuts de cette aventure ont pas
forcément été facile on y reviendra
après mais une fois que l'entreprise a
été établi que l'on à une propres locaux
il a fallu s'attacher à mettre en place
différents différentes méthodes
différentes habitudes pour créer cet
environnement plus propice à un naturel
au travail pour avoir plus de naturalité
au travail et la première anecdote ça a
commencé un matin où je recevais une
voiture électrique c'était la première
fois dans toute ma carrière où j'allais
avoir une voiture de fonction et donc
j'avais branché cette voiture dans la
prise électrique qui était devant
l'entrée du bureau et avec des collègues
je portais le bureau dans l'espace qui
mettait réservés et lorsque je me suis
assis je me suis rendu compte que
j'étais au premier étage avec une vitre
en angle qui donnait sur le parking avec
la voiture électrique garé juste devant
et que j'avais fait exactement l'inversé
de ce que je voulais créer et donc en
une semaine
ça m'a bien sûr un petit peu tourmenté
et en une semaine j'ai essayé de changer
ses mécanismes en achetant des casiers
notamment pour libérer les bureaux alors
libéré les bureaux c'est un bien grand
mot en fait c'est assez simple il s'agit
de venir chercher ses affaires dans un
casier le matin et les amener à un
bureau différent chaque jour
l'idée est assez simple est assez
courante on en parle dans dans pas mal
de bouquins d'entreprise libéré autres à
mettre en place c'est plus compliqué au
bout d'une semaine savais pas du tout
marché donc je me suis retrouvé à
acheter des fiches bristol et à coller
avec du scotch sur tous les bureaux en
écrivant lundi mardi mercredi et en
demandant à chacun de mettre son nom
pour qu'on s'assure que chacun puisse
changer de bureau tous les jours il y
avait plus aucun bureau individuel que
des espaces de travail partagés ou des
bureaux à 2 et puis petit à petit ça ça
a pris son envol et c'est maintenant une
des habitudes dans la société et ça fait
partie du quotidien
alors je vous raconte ça et en même
temps je pense que si je soumettais 7
cette magnifique idée à un référendum en
interne je ré à peine une petite
majorité
la raison principale c'est que ce type
de système il bénéficie aux quinze
vingts pour cent des personnes qui de
toute façon n'aurait pas eu un bureau
individuel n'aurait pas osé hausser la
voix pour avoir un mais une meilleure
place dans les bureaux partagés ne se
serait pas positionné pour prendre parti
ou pour avoir le quelque chose pour les
avantages et est donc ce système permet
de de mettre en place plus de naturalité
et de dès le début dès le début de sa
journée de travail quelque part de deux
cas c'est un peu le les habitudes et le
quotidien pour permettre plus de
naturalité
on a fait la même chose avec les
véhicules ça a été plus rapide j'ai
planté 4 clou j'ai pris les quatre clés
de voiture et j'ai dit à tout le monde
maintenant on prend la voiture dont on a
besoin et pas la voiture qui nous
revient de par notre statut notre titre
où notre fonction et donc ses deux
petits ces deux petites actions où on
était un début pour participer à cette à
cette libéralisation j'ai envie de dire
du travail mais surtout à plus de
naturel une deuxième petite action
qui était qui était plus dur pour moi
c'était la mise en place des cours de
sport dans l'entreprise on a tous des
vies trépidantes on rentre on a nos
enfants nos conjoints et donc prendre du
temps pour soi arriver à faire de
l'exercice c'est pas toujours aisé et
j'avais vécu ça ailleurs on y reviendra
et donc on a fait venir un coach sportif
avec des créneaux bien déterminée et
donc chaque semaine sur à la sortie du
bureau on pouvait aller prendre ce cours
de sport alors pendant six mois j'étais
tout seul je me suis posé beaucoup de
questions je pense que l'idée de voir
son patron en short ça devait en
réfréner certains ma femme m'a beaucoup
encouragée elle m'a dit nanan vas-y
continues tu vas voir ça va porter ses
fruits
je pense que mon physique s'améliorait
aussi donc ça devait participer aux
encouragements
malgré tout au bout de huit mois un an
il ya des gens qui sont venus et puis
petit à petit on s'est retrouvé 6 et 8
au cours de sport c'est un grand
soulagement parce que faire des ponts
tout seul on peut pas vraiment y
échapper par contre à 8 on peut faire
semblant de temps en temps mais ça a mis
du temps à se mettre en place c'est pas
aisée c'est pas facile d'arriver à
déconstruire cette espèce de carapace
que l'on passe beaucoup beaucoup de
temps et d'énergie à construire pour
apparaître ou être quelqu'un d'autre au
travail et donc toutes ces idées toutes
ces expériences sont venues d'une d'une
partie de ma vie
à la fin de mon école de commerce
j'avais fait un stage dans une société
d'assurances parisienne en
costume-cravate pendant un mois
je suis vite rendu compte que ça allait
pas être la bonne voie pour moi et il
était d'après avec
mon ami de l'époque qui est devenue ma
femme on avait économisé 500 $ et on
s'était acheté deux billets d'avion avec
un retour trois mois après pour los
angeles
les états unis on s'était dit quitte à
faire une école de commerce non pas
qu'on bossait beaucoup mais on s'est dit
au moins on va découvrir le monde du
commerce le le premier pays pour le
commerce et donc on est arrivé à los
angeles
on a loué une voiture on a été à l'hôtel
le lendemain on a été au motel le
troisième jour on a été au camping et le
quatrième matin on s'est réveillé
grelottant sur la plage serrés dans les
bras l'un de l'autre en se disant qu'est
ce qu'on fait là mon dieu ça caille à
des chiens sauvages partout autour de
nous et on n'a plus d'argent et donc on
a fait ce que font les gens qui n'ont
pas d'argent et qui cherche du travail
on a été au feu avec les mexicains qui
attendent et puis il ya des des camions
qui passent et qui propose du travail en
annonçant la durée le prix et la nature
des travaux et donc nous assez
rapidement un pick up est passé à dix
peintures 4 $ de l'heure pendant dix
jours nous aviez nos nounous et a10
sauter et là devant les mexicains médusé
parce que le marché était plutôt à 10 ou
11 dollars de l'heure on a sauté dans le
pick up parti pour dix jours de peinture
à 4 dollars de l'heure et là on n'a pas
cédé bonne journée mais c'était quand
même assez dur
on était très généreusement hébergé par
celui qui nous avait engagé et qui nous
louer pour 200 dollars une cabane de
chantier sur son terrain avec un lit
simple un wc et puis une plaque pour
faire chauffer les aliments et au bout
de dix jours on s'est dit que c'était
une expérience intéressante
enrichissante
peut-être pas exactement ce qu'on aurait
rêvé et donc on s'est dit qu'il fallait
qu'on fasse un travail qui était plus en
adéquation avec ce que l'on savait faire
ce que notre passé notre vécu notre
expérience on a une une idée très
logique que j'ai soumis à ma femme et
j'ai dit et si on faisait des nougat
glacé et elle a dit super et donc on est
parti au magasin acheter des petits pots
en carton avec des petits couvercle
essayer de trouver les ingrédients qu'on
avait en france pour cette recette de
nougat glacé qu'on n'a pas trouvé
et on est rentré dans notre cabane de
chantier
il a fallu faire du praliné alors quand
on n'a pas de praliné en sachet en fait
il faut faire du nougat avec des
noisettes et puis après il faut le
broyer en fait en tout petit donc on a
passé deux heures et demie avec le
talent de nos chaussures a cassé le
nougat pour faire de la poudre de
praliné et puis au bout de la nuit
c'était très sympa on a on avait cent
quarante quatre petits pots de nougat
glacé et là mon ami m'a dit mais
maintenant il faut qu'on mette des
étiquettes
on savait pas trop comment faire l ai
dit bon on va aller à l'université on
est étudiant et puis ça va bien se
passer
ça s'est passé exactement comme ça on
est rentré à l'université on était à
malibu pas n'importe où c'était une
cabane de chantier mais sur un terrain à
malibu et donc il y avait toutes les
rames de papier donc on a réussi à
trouver de du papier étiquettes et on a
écrit french louga glacée et on est
parti avec notre glaciaire vent de ça
est assez rapidement un magasin qui
vendait des sandwichs au poulet je crois
nous a pris nos nougat glacé à 1000
poster sur la sur la sur la porte french
louga glacée en dessert
et voilà et en fait cette expérience
était très révélatrice parce qu'en
faisant quelque chose même si c'est un
peu je joue la corde un peu loufoque
mais quelque chose que l'on savait faire
et que l'on avait pris du plaisir à
faire
on avait réussi à faire un projet qui
nous avait rapporté presque autant que
la peinture qu'on avait fait pendant dix
jours et dans lequel on avait pris du
plaisir il y avait une verticalité dans
notre projet alors on en a parfait parce
qu'il se trouve que la crème qu'on
utilisait fondé assez rapidement il ya
une vieille histoire mais les nougats
n'ont pas tenu on a enchaîné plusieurs
autres petits boulots et puis il a fallu
rentrer en france
reprendre nos études et il nous restait
six mois et puis après on avait un stage
de six mois
alors moi j'avais fait un prêt étudiant
je mettais en tt pour faire cette école
donc j'avais été emprunté de l'argent
il a fallu trouver un boulot plutôt
qu'un stage et à l'époque ça doit
toujours être le cas maintenant mais ça
faisait bien de faire du conseil le
conseil s'était quand même c'était quand
même assez chic comme travail et donc
j'ai envoyé des cv uniquement à des
sociétés de conseil
elles m'ont toutes répondu que c'était
pas possible parce que j'avais pas fais
une des trois grandes écoles parisiennes
et donc je me suis entêtée j'ai envoyé
plus de cvg et et les déposer aux
accueils des sociétés donc ça des côtes
est un peu en terme de société de
conseil mais j'étais toujours dans le
domaine d'activité est une société
américaine m'a contacté en me disant si
vous voulez on vous fait passer un
entretien
alors j'étais ravie jamais vraiment
compris cet entretien parce que je suis
arrivé dans une pièce il y avait un
psychologue qui m'a parlé j'étais dans
une forêt il y avait une cruche des
animaux de la forêt il fallait que je
dise quels animaux j'entendais y avait
un mur à passer c'est assez compliqué
assez confus à la fin du rendez-vous il
m'a dit que j'étais pris
j'étais scout avance a peut-être aidé je
sais pas et donc je suis rentré annoncé
ça à tout le monde en étant très fier
j'avais un job dans le conseil vous
savez toujours pas ce que ça voulait
dire d'ailleurs mais j'avais un job dans
le conseil et j'avais une voiture de
fonction j'ai tout ce qu'il fallait et
le soir même on m'a appelé des états
unis un des petits travail qu'on avait
fait pendant ces trois mois en me disant
si tu veux j'ai un job pour toi c'est
dans la vente et le marketing c'est un
peu à new york un peu los angeles
peut-être à san francisco ya pas
vraiment de salaire fixe
mais si tu veux passer des entretiens tu
as une chance d'avoir le job est au bout
de la nuit j'ai eu le job est donc le
matin j'ai annoncé fièrement à tout le
monde que je partais et que j'avais pris
ce job un petit peu plus incertain
certainement un trait de caractère et je
suis parti pour les états unis où j'ai
travaillé pendant un an pour cette
société puis j'ai fondé une autre
société dans le dans l'agro et dans le
bio et puis j'ai eu j'ai fondé ma
famille j'ai eu deux filles et puis la
vie m'a ramené en france quand j'ai mon
papa était malade il est parti maman est
partie quelques années après donc quand
j'ai su qu'il fallait rentrer en france
je me suis retrouvé face à une grosse
question c'était faire un cv et j'ai
essayé plein de logiciels qu'ils aient
des jolies mise en forme qu'en fait
c'était plus simple j'ai fondé une
société en prenant l'exemple américain
et en me disant surtout que j'allais
faire ce que je voulais faire je voulais
trouver cette naturalité jeu je me
voyais pas en fait
essayez de d'embellir les choses et
d'aller prendre un travail dans lequel
j'aurais été circoncis gérer été assez
en fait assez encadrée et donc cette
société je vais souhaiter différentes je
voulais une société plus alternatives
mais pas une société alternatif pour
être différent des autres et de
contestataires c'était vraiment pour
prendre du plaisir au travail pour
arriver à se faire en sorte que les
journées passent vite passe avec plein
de choses et passe naturellement sur
tout et donc je vous disais tout à
l'heure que ça n'a pas toujours été
facile au début
en fait on a failli mourir quatre cinq
fois pendant les quelques premières
années on avait dépensé tout l'argent et
je me souviendrai particulièrement d'une
d'une réunion d'actionnaires
assez compliqué il faut imaginer une
steicher notre avocat parisien donc une
très grande salle une belle table ronde
avec une dizaine de personnes en costume
sombre avec l'air pas très heureux et
moi qui arrive avec le bilan de la
société qui était exécrable et j'ai
revécu exactement ce que j'avais vécu
toute ma jeunesse en présentant mon
bulletin de notes à mes parents et ça a
été pire en fait parce que là je n'avais
pas d' excuses et donc on m'a proférées
beaucoup de conseils en mac
on m'a dit tout et son contraire on m'a
je crois fait beaucoup de reproches et à
ce moment là j'ai pendant cette espèce
de tempête d'informations confuses et
contraire j'ai pris conscience que
j'avais essayé de reproduire une société
américaine où tout allait aller très
vite
où ça allait être vite une grosse
société et qu'ils gagnaient de l'argent
et que ce que j'avais pas réussi à faire
aux états unis j'allais le faire
maintenant et il manquait un sens en
fait il manquait une verticalité à ce
projet et à ce moment là on a intégré la
r&d dans une pépinière d'entreprises
assez rapidement la production
alors comme on n'avait pas d'argent j'ai
été voir des agriculteurs et je leur
acheter des tanks à lait avec pour
quelques euros et venait me livrer en
tracteur pour la plupart et on a aménagé
un laboratoire comme ça c'est comme ça
que ça a commencé et ça ça nous a permis
de retrouver du sens et de redonner du
sens au projet et à partir de ce moment
là la société a commencé à bien marcher
en a grossi de 50 % par an jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
7 cette croissance elle était bien mais
comme on était dans notre élément on a
décidé on travaillait déjà avec des
personnes en situation de handicap
on envoyait des produits dans les esat
pour les faire conditionner là on a
franchi une autre étape on a demandé aux
esat de se joindre à nous et de venir
travailler tous les jours avec nous sur
la chaîne d'embouteillage à mettre les
bouteilles à mettre dans les cartons à
préparer les palettes enfin on était
tous ensemble et c'était un moment
vraiment de bonne heure on avait on
partageait beaucoup de choses et j'ai
été convoqué par le directeur de l'esat
qui m'a dit on a un vrai problème
tout le monde se bat pour venir chez
vous il ya qu'il ya vraiment des
batailles parce qu'ils sont très heureux
dans votre entreprise
alors je vous raconte
non pas pour flatter mon ego ou celui de
l'entreprise parce que deux ans après on
avait emménagé dans de nouveaux locaux
et j'ai été convoqué par le directeur de
les aides qui m'a dit on a un vrai
problème
plus personne ne veut venir chez vous et
là ça fait ça fait moins rire parce que
il a fallu se rendre compte de pourquoi
et en fait on avait grossi tellement
vite
on avait rajouté les murs on avait
rajouté des machines qui fait beaucoup
de bruit qui était stressante on avait
rajouté beaucoup de personnel donc ils
retrouvaient plus les mêmes personnes
on faisait plus attention à eux il
recevait des instructions leur parler
productivité et on avait totalement
oublié en fait le sens de ce qu'on était
venu faire à la base et du projet qu'on
voulait créer et je me souviendrai
toujours d'une anecdote d'ailleurs on
avait un projet de ré étiquetage des
bouteilles mal étiquetés et donc il y
avait un acheté une machine un convoyeur
sans fin avec une étiqueteuse au milieu
et donc je montrais comment ça marchait
il fallait prendre une bouteille la
poser sur le convoyeur et quand elle
passait devant l'étiqueteuse reprendre
la bouteille et la mettre dans un carton
et donc je demande à une des personnes
de le faire il pose la bouteille elle
tombe elle se casse un peu surpris je
refais la démonstration il recommence
quatre bouteilles sont tombés par terre
et au début je ne comprends pas je
comprenais pas et en réalité le fait de
travailler que des personnes en
situation de handicap ça nous ramène
face à nos réalités les plus profondes
c'est à dire que c'est la logique pure
il n'y a pas d' envie de mal faire ou
d'envié de bien faire
cette machine n'était pas pratique et si
en fait les bouteilles étaient pas
tomber à ce moment là elle serait tombée
pendant la journée près de la ligne de
production n'aura eu des risques de
bouts de verre cette machine était juste
mal foutu en fait il manquait un arrêt
au bout est donc cet exemple pour vous
dire qu'on a appris à retravailler
on a enfermé les machines qui faisait du
bruit dans des salles comme ça les
personnes en situation de handicap sont
en dehors de ces espaces ils ont - ils
sont moins soumis au stress et au bruit
des machines on a formé plus les
personnels qui travaillent avec eux on a
mis des référents qui vont se former au
sein de l'esat et puis surtout on a
retrouvé du plaisir et du bonheur à
travailler avec eux et on essaye avec
les équipes tous les jours de repenser
d'avoir une courbe de productivité mais
une courbe de bonheur à côté avec des
choses simples des éléments clés
et quand on arrive à faire une journée
où on a produit ce qu'on voulait
produire où on a pris du plaisir à le
faire
là on a vraiment réussi quelque chose
parce qu'arriver à produire quelque
chose dans le stress dans le mal être et
est dans une espèce de conditionnement
opaque on
c'est simple pour personne voilà cet
exemple pour vous dire que en réalité à
chaque étape de ma carrière je me suis
rendu compte que rien n'était acquis les
bureaux libéré c'est pas acquis
aujourd'hui le personnel en situation de
handicap
c'est un véritable bonheur un cadeau qui
nous font de venir travailler chez nous
tous les jours mais c'est pas acquis
parce que chaque jour il faut repenser à
leur accueil et en fait l'idéal est là
où on parle beaucoup de nouveaux mondes
d'entreprise de nouveaux formats de
nouvelles théories
la réalité c'est le bon sens c'est de se
reposer toujours les bonnes questions et
de se dire qu'est ce qu'on peut changer
comment est ce que maintenant qu'on est
là comment est-ce qu'on peut repasser à
l'étape d'après qu'est ce qu'on a mis en
place qui peut être n'est pas bien mis
en place et qu'il faut recommencer
donc je vous pose la question qu'est ce
que demain vous pourrez faire dans dans
votre monde du travail pour changer les
choses pour être plus naturel pour
enlever un peu cette carapace pour
souffler pour prendre plus de plaisir
dans ce que vous faites
soyez vous même soyez heureux merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]